it's great to welcome back to the
program today congressman ro
khanna representing california's 17th
district located
in the heart of silicon valley um
where to start right i mean i think
maybe the the first place would be
second stimulus given what's going on
with coronavirus
discussions of a payroll tax discussions
of
an extension or expansion
and to what degree of this enhanced
unemployment
what are your priorities what do you
think needs to happen and when
well first we have to be clear-eyed
about what the problem is the problem is
that they're not enough jobs i mean
people
don't have enough money to pay basic
rent to get groceries
so when people say oh these unemployment
checks are some disincentive to work
they're five
times the job seekers as there are jobs
and the irony is that by not giving this
money it's not just that we're doing
enormous damage to middle class and
working class families i mean
some are having foreclosures some aren't
being able to get enough
nutritious food for their kids it's also
that we're damaging the economy because
the economy is stalling
uh if people don't have money to spend
so uh the priority has to be to
stick to the six hundred dollars to get
that extended through the end of the
year
to get funding for states and localities
of course as you know david i've been
pushing for two thousand dollars a month
for
for people uh that wasn't in the house
bill so i don't want to
mislead people and it's unrealistic
that's going to be in the cards for this
but
but we have to stick to uh the 600 the
stimulus and
the fun money for uh state and local
governments i was initially
at least sort of loosely open to the
idea of the payroll tax cut that has
been floated by donald trump
i then changed my mind because i i
realized that it seems like a way
to weaken social security and medicare
and to then maybe use that deliberate
weakening as a reason to justify further
weakening or defunding so i ended up
deciding i didn't like it and in
particular because
the way i read it it's only a holiday it
is not
actually a cut in other words you would
then on your
taxes when you file potentially owe it
back and so i
ended up saying i don't like it where
are you on it
yeah i don't think it makes sense
particularly because we have the
challenge now
a business is not opening i mean if you
if you work for a restaurant or indoor
dining
it doesn't matter if you have a payroll
tax cut that's not going to
get you back to work until the virus is
under control and i
don't see it getting under control until
the next year until we have a vaccine
and better therapeutics so
uh you could argue in a in a traditional
recession
a payroll tax cut may provide some added
incentive to
to hiring uh it favors businesses over
workers but you may say okay
we need it as one tool but in a pandemic
where
uh the ability to create new jobs is
restricted by public health i
i don't think it makes sense so i'm
curious whether you have any other
as as a member of of the house insight
into what we might call the real case
numbers and what i mean by that is a
couple of examples are
we saw this leveling off after july 16th
which was exactly when data started
going to hhs instead of the cdc
it's a question mark although i'm not
alleging deliberate foul play yet
but then on top of that florida's
numbers have gone down but they stopped
testing on thursday because of the
hurricane and only restarted yesterday
so that would be a very clear reason why
we don't have a complete picture there
the california coveted 19 dashboard
yesterday put up a message saying that
for several days cases had been under
reported
although the reason why is not yet clear
to me are you working with the same data
the public is working with do you have
any other insights into into more
accurate data
we're working with the same data we
don't get any briefing of
better data and i think whether it's
deliberate uh
i don't know but it's certainly not
transparent i mean there's been a lot of
obfuscation there isn't a clear way of
uh collecting this data and the
reality is it's the hospitalizations and
the debts that
uh continue to uh be uh outrageous i
mean especially when you look at other
uh countries so the cases of course
matter but uh
the no one is can dispute the uh
data that we still don't have this under
control given the amount of debts that
we're unfortunately
facing and given the amount of
hospitalization we're facing
the topic of cases cases versus tests
if you don't test you don't find cases
case fatality rate
versus deaths per capita this all kind
of exploded on monday night in this
interview that the president gave to
axios's jonathan swann
i'm i'm guessing you saw the interview i
did i mean and and you know it's very
hard
look the president has one skill he's
very good at marketing and branding
but you can't spin death you can't
market when people are
in hospitals are filled and so he was
trying to say when the
relevant statistic is the percentage of
people with cases
uh who are dying in and it is true that
that
percentage has gone down as treatments
have uh improved
uh but uh that that is not the relevant
statistic the relevant statistic
is not uh what percentage of people are
getting covet or dying the relevant
statistic is why are so many americans
getting covered compared to other
countries and uh
i i think the president was unable to
spin his way out of that he obviously
understands the distinction he's just
hoping that he can
fool people but you can you can't fool
people when it's their own public health
that's interesting so you think he does
understand these
these issues in more detail than maybe
he lets on
and he's spinning because i actually
question whether he understands some of
this stuff
your sense is that it's deliberate and
that it's optics
i think in that case he's i i mean i
don't think he's he's deeply reflective
but i think he looks for the numbers
that
make the most sense and he tries to uh
to put them out if the
if the death rates were lower he would
have put that number out so i
i think his modus operandi his whole
life has been uh
take any news uh exaggerated a bit
uh make it sound great and to your
advantage and in many cases
that has worked with him with uh people
who are busy in their lives and don't
have the time to look through
long articles the the challenge here is
uh
suddenly people are taking the time uh
to pay attention
uh because it's their own health it's
their parents health it's their
neighbor's health
and so they have far more details and
when you have a situation of an engaged
citizenry on an issue
trump's strategy really falls flat and
that's why i think
you've seen him struggling what do you
think
or i guess let me rephrase it in a
different way i imagine
that if you were scheduled to do an
interview
that your staff felt very strongly would
potentially be a disaster
that you logic would reach you and you
might
listen to advice that says this maybe
isn't a good interview to do
the context is how do you think these
insane interviews are even happening
with the president
is it that he doesn't listen to his
staff and that he believes he'll always
come out on top i mean i'm trying to
understand how these things are
happening so frequently
yeah i think from his perspective he's
succeeded to
quote unquote succeed in a material
sense and a lot of things he's done in
life he's managed to
talk himself out of bankruptcies he came
out of nowhere and became president of
the united states and i think he has a
lot of
self-confidence in uh hubris that
his view is the more exposure the better
and that he can talk his way
out of anything and this is a a common
problem when people
become president obviously it's
massively exaggerated in
trump's case where he does not have the
humility to to see his own own
weaknesses and i think that's creating a
large amount of the problems for him so
what what does that get you thinking
about in terms of
potential biden versus trump debates
i've said from a practical standpoint
i can't think of an election i voted in
where i care less about seeing debates i
mean it's just
i just think i have more than enough
information uniquely so in this case to
make a decision and that's that's to
vote for joe biden
there's speculation about joe biden
the debates are better for biden or the
debates are better for trump and a lot
of that depends on
you know what your belief is about the
cognitive state of of either or both of
them
what's your sense about the debates not
generally but in this particular case
well i think that biden uh will debate
and should debate because i think the
story of him
uh not debating would be a much bigger
deal and lead to speculation that is
unfair and wrong and i think people
underestimate by then i mean if you look
uh i
as you know i co-chaired the bernie
sanders campaign we were very excited
when we had a one-on-one opportunity
with biden
and i think everyone would tell you that
biden held his own i mean it was not a
knockout punch for
uh bernie sanders if anything you think
it was probably a draw so
my sense is biden's debate skills
improved a lot uh through the course of
the primary
uh and i think one of the mistakes
donald trump is making is by so
uh putting all his chips in these
debates
and setting the bar so low uh if
uh biden has a satisfactory performance
uh he's gonna really i think get the
upper hand and i i i think biden's
perfectly capable of having a solid
performance that's super interesting
because i remember that in the sort of
uh uh twitter bernie space before the
one-on-one debates
there were very high hopes that joe
biden was going to implode and this was
going that was going to be the moment at
which bernie took over and as you
mentioned
it really was a draw in a sense i do
think that the heavy focus on
coronavirus probably helped joe biden to
some degree and there was less focus in
that debate
on other issues but so even within
the bernie camp there were high hopes
about that one-on-one debate
yeah no i mean that was sort of our
final uh hope to try to shake up the
race obviously we were doing very well
headed into super tuesday we had a dip
disappointing super tuesday uh it was uh
not anticipated that everyone would
withdraw and endorse biden
it's a free country people can do that
but really no one uh thought the
establishment would coalesce around by
them that quickly
and so we needed a game changer and we
thought this debate was
a place uh we could have one i mean
bernie objectively i think had done much
better in
a lot of the debates leading up to that
debate than biden had
but biden has exceeded expectations in
in that debate
and so uh he's certainly capable of of
doing that
and uh so i i think trump is making a
mistake if he's
putting all his eggs in in that basket
so let's talk a little bit about the
last three months here to the election
where
uh every member of the house is up for
re-election
33 plus two senate seats are available
and of course it's the presidential
election
there are some in my audience that are
feeling very confident about the
presidential piece
seeing polls that have joe biden doing
very well
today i went through and pointed out for
example
in a recent poll where joe biden is
winning by nine when you look at the
margin of error
that could be actually only a 2.4
percent lead for joe biden and hillary
won by 2.2 in 2016
at the popular vote level but lost the
electoral college
when i look at state by state polling
which looks quite good for joe biden
the state polling was not great in 2016.
national was good in other words hillary
was up three and one by 2.2 that's
that's great
wisconsin said hillary was going to win
and she lost so
i am very cautious about any complacency
at all going into this election while
some are extraordinarily confident
what do you think is the right
perspective on the data
i think caution is is better i would say
if the election were tomorrow
uh biden uh would win because i think
the
the polling is so overwhelming in one
direction but the election is not
tomorrow and
there's a lot that can happen in the
next 90 days the debates being one of
them that doesn't mean
don't debate uh because that would be an
issue in and of itself but the point is
that the conventions haven't happened
the debates haven't happened
we don't know what uh the economy is
going to look like
come end of september and october we
don't know whether coronavirus is going
to be on the retreat in in some sense
and getting slightly better or
whether it's getting uh worse we don't
know the impact of who he picks as a
vice president
so this is not a situation of george w
bush in 2008 where george w
bush had collapsed into the 30s and
really the american people had
uh totally written him off and i don't
think it's even at the level
of jimmy carter who've been i really
admire jimmy carter i think he was
an exceptional person but uh trump has
been stubbornly at 40 41 42 that means
if he gets a five-point swing and gets
his approval up to 45
this is a very competitive race and then
you put it you put
on top of that this fact that uh the
voter suppression
the the the difficulty of mail-in
ballots
the energetic nature of his base uh and
i think we have to
assume that this is going to be a drag
out fight
when it comes to the senate it looks to
me as though
if democrats keep the house which you
are projected to
if joe biden were to win that a lot of
what
gets done in the next two years depends
on whether democrats can take control of
the senate and
i've looked at the races up and down and
certainly there's a path now that is a
clearer path than than it was 6 and 12
and 18 months ago
what races are you looking at in the
senate and what's your sense of where
that might go
well i think arizona we've got a great
job with mark kelly i think in north
carolina with cunningham we have a very
very strong shot
i think susan collins is in deep trouble
i think steve bullock and
montana has made that race much more
competitive uh
our candidates are doing very well but i
think it largely depends on
on biden i mean if biden has a kind of
win that his polling currently shows i
think we have a very good chance of
carrying the senate if this race
tightens uh as i fear it may
uh then you know our chances of getting
it
the sweep we need in senate seats uh
becomes harder and it became harder
where
some of the the candidates won the right
candidates from the republican side in
the
kansas primary and and you know they
have and they've been fortunate not to
elect some of the most crazy people
where we could have had a
a pickup opportunity last thing i want
to touch
on there's been this idea now of
could an election be delayed what would
it look like
what would be the reasons are there ways
for the president to stay
in the oval office and i've tried not to
give this more attention than it
deserves because when when it comes
right down to it we've not had a federal
election delay in the history of this
country
on january 20th trump stops being
president if he's not re-elected and
then you know a series of other things
happen
is this at all being taken seriously
among you and your colleagues is there
is there a discussion of this or is it
basically just not not being paid
attention to
my concern is not that he's gonna delay
the election my concern is
that uh there is a early reporting of
election day results
where which tend to favor republicans
traditionally
and he may be and have an early lead in
one of these battleground states
and then there's delay and not proper
counting of absentee ballots
and if you have a few percent election
in a place like florida in a place like
wisconsin
that there's tremendous pressure put on
the state legislatures
to certify uh those states in in favor
of trump
so uh i i don't see a situation where
the state certified joe biden the house
and senate certified joe biden and
donald trump stays in the white house i
think a far more risky situation is like
1876 where you
actually have state legislatures
working conspiring with the white house
uh to
uh give the result to trump on on
on a close call and that that to me is
the the disenfranchisement and
and states uh calling it for trump or
what
what i think are the deep concerns yeah
i'm not conspiratorial by nature but
after months of railing against vote by
mail
when donald trump tweeted two days ago
or three days ago
everybody in florida should vote by mail
my mind immediately goes to
what does he know about ron desantis's
plans that now all of a sudden make him
very
into the idea of florida voting by mail
and i think it goes along the lines
you're talking about which is the role
that the state and secretaries of states
may have yeah and i mean look he's
uh doesn't even try to get principal
uh a any uh any due i mean he's
basically saying okay
in the states that i need absentee
voting please vote absentee in the
states where absentee voting may hurt me
don't do it
uh it's just raw uh power but this is
they understand that if it were an
election where which was clean where
everyone who should be
wanting to should be voting and wanting
to vote votes uh trump can't overcome
those numbers so
uh the the disenfranchisement the try
trying to create
confusion uh and then the biggest risk i
think is this idea that donald trump
imagined up on election day he's up by a
couple points in
wisconsin or florida even if a week
later we know he's going to lose by four
or five points
you could see him declaring victory and
it becomes
much harder than for the states where
those state legislators are in trump
heavy districts to do the right thing
and so that that i think is the bigger
uh bigger fear of how they would cheat
or take to take the election
i uh completely agree and it's exactly
the point uh that i've been making
congressman ro
khanna representing california 17th
district
always a pleasure and i really
appreciate your time appreciate it david
appreciate all of your commentary and
look forward to being back on